titoff
ouais vous amis ça comme ça si à un
moment ait quelque chose qui vous plaît
pas dans l'émission d'accord ben ça va
beaucoup plus que tu as dis là
vous arrêtez donc benoît alternance
benoît allard nancy 2-3 de scènes de
comédie et de scène à grand spectacle
évidemment tout un jour entre vous deux
une grande complicité effectivement et
puis et puis aussi des scènes très
spectaculaires comme par exemple la
grande route paris ouais sur les tubas
et oui c'est extrêmement impressionnant
que nous quand on l'a lu le scénario
c'est facile à écrire de la grande roue
s'est décrochée dans tout les tuileries
écrit safran s'incliner après comme
tournée donc nous en tant qu'acteur on
s'est dit si jamais c'est fait par des
par la casse et on m'a l'air d'une seule
une bande de tâcheron donc nous quand on
l'a vu
c'est vraiment un moment très très
impressionnés là je rends hommage à
frédéric forestier qui a fait un boulot
mais c'est très très bien il est tout
jeune fred est vraiment il est il est
parti pour une carrière américaine
dirions-nous française tout ça avant
très très impressionnant
on écrivait pu épuiser la france
orange vient je vous normal vous taire
donc tournage assez éprouvant s'est
passé deux mois dans les glaces au bord
de la piscine de l'hôtel
banier rixe à une piscine j'ai gagné
beaucoup d'argent je gagnais
raisonnablement où je gagnais pas mal
gagné ma vie sur ce film c'est vrai
c'est vrai franchement vous dites c'est
obscène c'est toujours obscène s'ils
fument ne marche pas là ses potes les
yeux non c'est pas cette prime
fonctionne très très bien alors que j'ai
pas de honte à avoir quand le film ne
marche pas vous vous tapez quand même
deux trois mois de honte grâce mais
après vous apprêtez à vous c'est
d'autant plus cher que vous ne vous
trouvez pas bon acteur vous dit un jour
ils vont s'en rendre compte ils vont me
demander de rembourser
oui j'ai toujours l'impression qu'on va
me dire on s'est trompé il va falloir
tout rendre quand on me dit que vous
êtes le nouveau beau vivent ça ça fait
plaisir
non non je suis très très flatté mais je
je suis moi l'ajustement
et
alors vous étiez benoît à namur en
belgique dans une famille relativement
modeste un frère une soeur après une
soeur qui se troue sainte règle et si
vos parents se sont séparés quand vous
aviez 5 ans et vous y retrouver interne
pratiquement dès l'âge de 7-8 ans ouais
enfin c'est pas très drôle vous dit vous
n'avez jamais connu de noël en famille
non c'est vrai parce que j'étais tout le
temps dans les internats où les les
colonies de vacances ou lewis est vrai j
j'avais fêté noël en famille mais en
france pas très drôle si on l'a regardé
sur la lisez comme vous la lisez sur le
papier ça peut paraître tragique mais
moi je me suis beaucoup j'ai eu une
enfance magnifique ouais moi je trouve
qu'elle était magnifique
votre père crier beaucoup mais c'est
vrai c'était quelqu'un d'assez bourru sa
routier il savait pas dire je t elle il
ya des gens comme ça
oui oui c'est vrai oui enfin bon
comment dirais-je c'est didier délicat
de dire ces choses là je pense que où le
froid il ya des gens qui le crime
différemment n'hésitez pas pardon c'est
pas son genre quoi il n'est pas
quelqu'un de très expansif
non il n'est pas très expansif oui j'en
ai pas en fait dès l'âge de 17 ans vous
êtes autonome et vous prenez un
appartement au dessus duquel résonnent
bodmer certaine facilité votre mère
était commerçante assez libérale c'est
sympa c'est que j'ai beaucoup de chance
et alors s'ensuit une longue période
d'hésitation entre les études et le
travail
vous savez pas vraiment quoi faire
surtout leur envie de rien faire du tout
13 avril à l'école même en échouant
j'étais très heureux dans les endroits
où il y avait beaucoup de gens est alors
dans l'année de vos 18 ans vous avez que
mission de réaliser une affiche pour un
spectacle de théâtre locale êtes bien
renseigné intériste exact j'aime leur
éclat dans ces cas là ma faim
mais
à
grand merci des enfants n'ont donc voilà
où devait réaliser cette affiche pour un
théâtre locale et puis comme l'acteur a
eu un accident
oui c'est vrai coup de bol à cause de
leur carrière
ça tient à peu de choses près c'est
parce que je voulais rencontrer là une
jeune fille qui se trouvait dans la
classe qui jouait dans cette pièce de
théâtre en fait j'ai fait du théâtre et
du cinéma uniquement pour rencontrer ses
deux filles qui étaient dans la classe à
côté a pu rencontrer ans dans la fiche
parce qu'elle en avait rien à [ __ ]
dans le pré mais qui faisait la fiche
d'offres que après donc vous faites de
petits rôles dans de petits films avec
votre pote rémy belvaux vous continuez
le dessin saint-luc à bruxelles fait une
école fameuse 1 pour la pour la bande
dessinée
et si comme ça que naîtra ce film culte
d'une génération c'est arrivé près de
chez vous co écrit par vous avec reini
belvaux et andré bonzel